hi this is Jeff Thumb director of the
Great Race and we're continuing our
series of how-to videos and today we're
going to talk about two things
preparing your car for the Great Race
and then how to make a performance chart
for the Great Race now the Great Race is
a lot of fun and to maximize that
experience on the race you want to make
sure your car is prepared because it
doesn't matter how good you are at the
competition portion if you're on the
side of the road because your car's not
prepared that's going to ruin your day
and maybe even the entire event for you
and you know it's car guys I don't need
to tell you you need to get your cars
out and you need to run them run them
down the road a lot before the great
race you'd be surprised at how many cars
break on the very first day of the great
race because they're not prepared the
first day of the great race is the
number one day for picking up cars now
we do have a sweet truck that's
available and we will not leave you
behind we'll pick you up but boy I hate
picking up rookies especially on the
first day because the cars are not
prepared now to prepare your car as I
said you need to get out and use it and
you need to use it a lot before the
great race you also need to familiarize
yourself with the rules and regulations
of the event and those are sent to you
and you're welcome email package when
you first enter the race you need to
know what modifications you can and
cannot have on the car with with or
without a penalty so some of the most
common things are conversions to
hydraulic brakes especially like a Model
A's conversion to 12-volt well all this
is allowed with no penalty you will also
need to make sure that you have
seatbelts in your car even if your car
did not come equipped with seat belts
you will have to have seatbelts in your
car so the whole idea is when you get to
the great race and it starts that you're
prepared and your car is prepared now
how do I prepare for the actual
competition well that comes with making
a performance chart the booklet we've
mentioned in several videos that we give
to rookies is a how to prepare for the
Great Race it has very very valuable
information for how to make a
performance chart for your car I would
read it and reread it several times it
will tell you in full detail how to make
this performance chart
there's even a sample set of performance
charts for a 1936 Packard what you can
use it would be better than nothing but
I'm gonna give you a quick simple way to
make a performance chart for your car
you're gonna need to take your car and a
stopwatch and find two objects out on
the road find a deserted Road let's call
it telephone poles you're gonna find two
telephone poles and you're gonna drive
each speed every five miles per hour
between 15 and 50 miles per hour 15 20
25 and so on up to 50 and you can drive
each speed through holding speed and
using your stopwatch I'm going to use
this example at 30 miles per hour so at
30 miles per hour you're gonna drive
through these two telephone poles you're
gonna start your stopwatch at the first
one now you're already at 30 miles an
hour when you hit the first stop sign or
the telephone pole when you cross that
telephone pole you start the stopwatch
and it settle in telephone pole you stop
the stopwatch now remember we're doing
in this example 30 miles per hour let's
say that the time between those two
telephone poles at 30 miles per hour is
45 seconds now you're gonna go back to
the telephone pole the first telephone
pole and you're going to pull up and
stop even with the telephone pole get a
count down the five four three two one
and on go start the stopwatch and start
the car and you're going to drive
through the same distance
to the next telephone pole as you pass
the next telephone pole again at 30
miles per hour you're gonna stop the
stopwatch now your time is going to be
48 seconds what does that tell you that
tells you that it driving through it
straight without stopping is at 30 miles
per hour is 45 seconds but starting from
a standstill at the first stop at
Oakland pole driving through the second
telephone pole is 48 seconds so at 30
miles per hour you have a three-second
loss and started that's how you develop
your loss at a start well how do I
figure out how much time it takes me to
break still fairly simple use the same
two telephone poles this time you run
through you're already doing 30 miles an
hour when you pass the first telephone
pole
when you get past the telephone pole of
50 yards have the driver stop come to a
complete stop just they would at any
stop sign this is why you need to be on
a deserted road to do this as soon as
you stop start back go back to 30 miles
per hour continue through the last
second telephone poles start to stop
your stopwatch now your stopwatch says
50 seconds what does that tell you
well you did 30 miles an hour straight
through and it was at 45 seconds you did
started from a dead stop at the first
stop first telephone pole and it was 45
seconds no 48 seconds which does use a
three second loss in your starting now
you've driven through stopped and
started in the middle and it was 50
seconds we already know it's three
seconds to start so if you take the 45
original and the 50 on a start and stop
and you pull out the three seconds we
are
you know that it takes to start from 30
miles an hour now you know it takes you
2 seconds to stop from 30 miles an hour
as well might seem a little complicated
but it's not it's pretty straightforward
you can use any two objects that you
want and you need to do this at every
speed from every five miles an hour
between 15 and 50 and I would urge you
again to use the booklet it goes into
great detail of how to how to make this
happen so you have a successful Great
Race